issues or concerns that they've had with
what they've been doing in order to do
these own killing these particular
photos either of you would like to put
up there go ahead oh and a problem the
only one of mine there's 13 or 20 tony
is my 20 is my little taller see you did
hit pitchers out there huh I told you a
picture self I know I've got a 60 on
reverse further for my mania crops
because I'm primarily a grain grower but
I built that to roll for my strawberries
and it's a pretty simple little machine
and it usually can tell right there it
works awfully good if you're as long as
you have your cover crop or clean ground
ahead of time in other words that's a
field that had Ryan it was sprayed in
the fall and I use that for strawberries
so I'm doing that about the first week
in april or last week in march as soon
as i can get in the field to get it
ready so i can plant my strawberries in
april and all it is is to chisel shanks
and then two sets of closing covering
for Coulter's on the back to shape up a
ridge it's a two mo machine I pull it
about 13 or 14 inches deep and I'm
pulling it with a 30 horsepower tractor
right there is all but there's no fancy
equipment on it if I had the only thing
it would have to be different if I had a
cover crop a heavy cover crop ahead
might need a coulter in front of that to
cut through and there's a toolbar in the
front there i made so i could put one on
but i've never needed it so i've only
got just to shoot the chisels in the
middle and the Coulter's in the back
about 12 13 or 14 inches no fertilizer
anything I meet be easy to put a little
tank on there and run a hose with the
nozzle down the back of each chisel
point you could put fertilizer eight
inches deep if you were going to grow
sweet corn or some other crop that
needed nitrogen you could put it on with
that eight inches or so put about half
your nitrogen on early with that and
then put the other half on top when you
plant your crop but I don't need it for
the berries so I don't do that and then
where is it under third slide um Betsy
yeah my machine isn't a nurse too big
Betsy where is an unrehearsed lied over
number number 16 looks like a good bet
okay one above it too isn't it one I
might be one right yeah yeah that might
be a nun reverb that's there that one is
the one above it nine yeah that's an
Andhra first machine that's like mine
well that that the only difference
between that and mine I've replaced
those baskets on the back with colder
packer liberal rollers kulta Packer
wheels I think it makes a little more
that makes it better wrote a plant and
because the firm's the soil a little bit
I like that machine because it's got the
straight shanks we've all were trying to
do with that is to make a slot in the
ground that the plant roots can follow
down is below the compacted layers I
like that better than the parabolic
shanks because the parabolic shanks pull
up more stones than that will so that's
a if you're in a stony situation that
machine is a cleaner one
run I've been used in mine for 15 years
and it pulls you know it takes about
half as much power to pull it now as it
did when I started it gets better and
better every single year in fact under
the point now on my gravel and good loan
ground I don't do that anymore I just
stripped to a plan on top of the ground
but in the heavier ground heavy clay I
still do that and but I put color pack
of wheels on the back to break the clods
up and do a little compaction on the
road or firm it up before I'm going to
plant I prefer to do it in the fall if
somebody needed to know when in which
case I take that back piece right off I
don't need to firm the slot and I don't
need to use the basket so i just have
the closing discs in the big shank in
the front in the fall and then let
mother nature take care of firming up
the row and then just go in and plant on
at the spring so I prefer to do it to
fall if I have a choice loosen the
ground and get that slot made so that
freezing and thawing and whatever will
take care of it but if you have to do it
in the spring then you need either that
basket or color would pack of wheels or
something on the back or you're going to
have the soil is going to be too loose
to planning well you can plant in it but
it's better if you put something on the
back there it doesn't really break up
the five set well no that was a the
problem George did mine before I started
he and I talked about I said I wonder
what would happen if you put a color
pack a wheel on there because I've got
cloud of your ground and he does and
works better yeah that he did it
afterwards and that was that seemed to
be the answer for breaking the clouds
out especially in that we had a dry year
and then we really wanted people to go
to the closet Packers that's right
that's right if it was with maybe then
the baskets okay because it'll probably
break the clogs up if it's wet anyway
the question of two things in a heavy
ground which is where that thing really
is needed you're going to get clods if
you get clods you got to do something
with them you don't just leave them
there but dry out and get hard and then
try to plant through them so you you
know if the basket will break up your
clods fine and dandy if it won't the Col
de packer wheels will do a better job of
that but if it's really really wet
you're going to get too much with that
you know then you've got to take the
spring off and do everything to keep it
so it doesn't push down
quite so hard and so it's a it's a
question every year what the ground is
like what kind of soil is that what
field you're in you don't do it the same
way in every field every year you have
to be able to make some adjustments but
the shank the cutting disk in the front
the shank and then the two closing discs
stay the same no matter where you are
and that's all you use in the fall and
and that's what another reason i like to
do it in the fall because it's generally
dryer in the fall the soil is in better
condition and you're not worried about
it wet in the spring because if you do
it in the fall make your role in the
fall it'll dry out in the spring if it's
a wet spring all by itself and the
clouds will be gone from from mother
nature so you don't have to deal with
those issues if you do your your detail
or you're ripping in the fall I think
that's a better way to go one of one of
the things that I would have I've kind
of toyed with the idea of adding to mine
was a set of rolling baskets and not
rolling baskets but trash trash cleaners
in front of the the Ripper point okay
yeah yeah just when we were using the
one real setter to set either seeds or
transplants trash can be a problem if
you let it get to too tall and even if
you kill it around up if you let it get
woody at all you got to kind of keep it
you can spray it when it's in a grass
single blade for more you're going to
run the problems well what what slide is
that that you're referring to here now
with the trash wheel um can you hear me
Carol it's number eight number eight
okay yep so I built my unit I didn't
leave enough room to put any stuff on I
didn't really think about pre-roll I was
trying to get real real aggressive point
on a thing to get down deep and I've
tried to put stuff after it and it
doesn't really work i guess i could
probably put a set of real cleaners
right before my my hill or dis in the
back you know that could possibly work
or run it after run the Hiller dis and
then run these after I
I've looked at the thing several
different ways and I've got it set
pretty good so it works well the way it
is so I just I've never really taken the
time to mess with putting these things
on but see those in that picture are
like my planner you put those on the
front of your planner so I'm sick I
wondering why you couldn't put those on
the front of your transplanter that's
where they belong but your ghostly
narrow just before you get right there
with the transplant yeah but you have to
don't you have to go like five miles an
hour or something in the making work now
they'll work that slow yep kind of
transpiring well I'm not sure they work
and a half a mile properly the floating
ones which you got to death well that's
right that's it does a nice job of
cleaning even at people or even like a
quarter mile an hour hema well okay put
your garden ridge okay okay try to rape
the club and that's then you don't have
to deal with the herbage out of the way
they got to be free-floating right they
gotta have those wheels Treader wheels
on the side dig depth wheel so they
don't go too deep okay the floating ones
will never make a gouge a trench great
right do any get you know our complex
top topography hill savings everything
they will gouge you go to faster you
have too deep and then you end up with a
depression with all this junk on the
side flex water yeah elected collects
water and it's to murder a few vets
processing snap beans or dried meat as
you've got your rows below the starting
below the level of the soil that means
they have that mini mounds still intact
so Carroll indem gym and Lynn and George
I have this picture up this is on him
out of the trash wheels and I do know
that i'ma firth is made an adept they
have created a mounting unit for the in
front of the cutting disc that you can
actually okay that's where it belongs
that's where it belongs in front of the
cutting discs they made a unit so I
wanted to make sure folks were knew
about that um before we move around for
questions I wanted to see your cop
outfit you had any other comments on how
you got started um
but basically I was struggling on on
either dry years or excessively dry
years or excessively wet years my ground
would pond on a wet year and on a dry
year nothing would grow that's kind of
what got me started into it and between
a little urgent from George and Gary
sweet we had tried zone tillage without
any ripping first year I tried it I
thought that's where I had to go to work
it was beautiful we got a rain right
after I planted everything came out of
the ground the pumpkins were beautiful
that year the next year i expanded again
hit George plant my winter squash and
pumpkins and it was a total failure it
was so dry that here the plants didn't
germinate when they did germinate they
really didn't grow well the missing
ingredient seem to be the ripping and
making that slot giving it a place to
grow the following year if you go back
to your pictures there again I started
out with a one shank ripper that it was
just a subsoiler I had that I use for
the drainage it's pitcher number six
that's that was my first experiment
right there i took that went down
through i ripped four rows in the middle
of a tomato field on a clay knoll where
nothing would grow anyway with the
attitude that if nothing if it doesn't
work well nothing was going to grow
there anyway so i'm really not out
anything i went through with that then
followed up with a a cub with Hiller
discs on it we went back and forth
through a couple times sprayed the
clouds up Trent used a conventional
transplant or planted into it first
thing I noticed was a transplanter
worked better than it ever had before
planning on that Mound a nice soft mound
second thing I noticed was again it was
a start out to be a really dry spring
the transplants hit the ground and just
started running from the minute they hit
the ground the plants looked way better
than the tomato plants on either side of
the four rows the test strip all season
long I mean is that they grew faster it
looked like a you know use a different
fertilizer program or something
everything was the same we had pictures
somewhere I don't know if we have him
here today or not but the final result
would
the yield difference was unbelievable
quality everything the tomatoes are
beard it was more tomatoes on a plant so
that was that's what got me started and
I'd been experimenting ever since I
think it's a picture 28 or 21 or
something the following year I built a
two row unit which included the Hiller
disc tried to do everything in one pass
was in the PTT you sent us ok ok but
similar to George's actually but the
only difference is I've got straight
shanks on mine and I've got a set of
spider wheels that run behind the ripper
ripper shank to kind of break up the
clods and it does roll some of the sad
and stuff out of the way a little bit
and then it's followed up by two Hiller
discs there the concave Hillard is ok to
throw a nice but the mound I throw is
probably like 8-10 inches high I like a
good high mountain so after it settles
you've still got a mound there but every
experiment that I've done with this so
far has been positive from planning for
Rose I've take that to Row Ripper and go
out the middle of a 10 acre corn field
in rip for rose plant directly into it
you can drive across the end of the
field on a pickup truck don't even get
other truck the corn is six inches to a
foot taller than the corn on both sides
of it it's just I have had one bad
experience with it yet it seems for me
it's been the way to go yes I light soil
right yeah it wouldn't perk it up great
which is not unusual I'm vegetable soil
tillage pins yeah so so so I i wanted to
just cut it here I wanted to take it to
a minute to go around all the locations
and see if we had any questions because
we wanted to move on to some the growers
on Long Island who have diffused
different equipment so before we move on
i'm going to add look at the growers
that are here with us in the room in
ithaca to have any questions for George
yes go ahead
George when you when you till in the
fall do you have a hard time finding
your rose in the spring no no because I
end up with about a six inch six or
seven inch wide clean till strip there
with a mound and it's still visible on
the spring I mean you have to do fall
weed control is the best option for zone
tillage anyway and so the strips are
still there in the spring I don't have
any trouble we have one more question
from Ithaca are you doing that zone
chillin in the fall and do a cover crop
that a winter kill or two awry that's
still alive in the spring well ya know
both a lot of it is into soybean ground
that's going to go back to sweet corn or
something so there isn't any cover crop
there it's too late I'm a plan try but
then i do the deep till early enough
that the rise is barely coming up it
comes up afterwards and then we have to
kill it in the spring but but uh I've
done it well like I for my pumpkins I
usually do it either very late in the
fall or very early in the spring into
standing ride and again I don't have a
problem getting through the Rye or
seeing the rose when I get ready to
plant let's killed right all right so
you won't you won't want to try to plant
into a green right you don't want to
plan anything green you can't help but
that side they'll just it'll make a mess
and it'll ball up and you've got to kill
that crop whatever you plan in to make
sure it's dead if that if that zone
builder has a good cutting disk ahead of
that shank you can zone bill through
anything but you can't plant through
anything green you want to make sure
everything is dead when you get there
with a planner takes about a month you
want to spray what I found is three
weeks to four weeks before three weeks
in yeah can we move on to Long Island
look 14 George Earle in yeah we've got a
couple questions okay what kind of
plants what kind of plant or are you
using me John Dear John Deere 7000 here
I also use a conventional it's an old
new idea transplant yeah
I use that then I have a newer style
with a the finger pick up for the
transplants also but there's nothing
I've done nothing no modifications to
the transplant is we just if you if you
build a clean mound that's something I
fail to mention earlier too you're going
to have seasons where your you may have
to go back over that where you're ripped
I with a two row Ripper I will go
through it one direction if I don't have
a nice clean seedbed I will turn around
and go back the opposite direction at
the same time and that usually does
enough to it breaks up the clouds and
clears up the gives you a nice clean
seedbed a nice mountain to plant in to
make sure it looks good you want it to
look the way you got to be happy with
the way it looks or you won't be happy
with the end result so just make sure
you got a clean place to start any other
questions from Long Island yeah i'm just
wondering about having a rolling basket
followed by a cult attacker or some of
our growers have tried to rolling
baskets just to have a really good bed
and this would be zoned building in the
spring what do you think of those ideas
ah don't see any reason it wouldn't work
I've not done that I've either had the
basket or the cold a packer I haven't
had both but I shouldn't be all right I
think the key in if is to have the
colder Packer one place or the other so
you get the firming up of that row if
you're going to do it to spring you
don't have very long for mother nature
to do that for you so you want to do it
yourself oh I have like two questions
one is there was a comment made that
someone doing the ripping along with his
own building after a period of time was
able to not do that ripping anymore how
long did it take before he got to that
point I don't know I'm at the point now
it's been different each field is
different my heavy ground I still do the
ripping the heavy clay because it just
seals up so hard every year but I
haven't done any ripping on some
gravelly loam around
I live probably for the last oh I'd say
five years and I've been doing zone
tillage for 15 or 16 years so I probably
could have quit quicker the Ray Rossum
when I started tried to tell everybody
that he could do it two years in a row
you do you're ripping one year and then
you split the Middle's the second year
and then you don't have to do it anymore
as long as you don't mess the soil up
and he may have been right i don't know
i never had nerve enough to do it that
way so I probably went six or seven or
eight years before I quit doing the
ripping on the good soil but the heavy
clay I still rip every year thank you
and then the second question is you have
a John Deere 7000 you have a gang of
Coulter's in front of each planner oh no
I have a I'm up until this year I've had
the old unverferth cart that had a tank
and Coulter's on the cart three
Coulter's to the row and pulled the
planter behind it this year I'm going to
have a set of trash wheels like you saw
on that other picture on the front with
a single disc fertilizer applicator off
to one side for each row and I won't use
the card anymore I don't need it the car
was needed when I started because if you
put the Coulter's on the planner 15
years ago you couldn't get the planner
in the ground the ground was too hard so
I got the cart which you could put 500
gallons of fertilizer in their water or
whatever for weight and you could get
the thing in the ground but I'm to the
point now I don't have any problem
anymore so this from now on I won't use
a cart I have the same your thousand
planner it has a no-till Coulter just
one Coulter in front of each row it does
a pretty good job I have two neighbors
that have switched to a zone till no
tell if you want to call it that both of
them have Kensi planners and they
started with a coulter like the one
that's in that picture there the single
cutting Coulter in the front no-till
Colter with a fertilizer unit on and
they don't do the deep ripping anymore
they're in the same shape I'm in but
their grain producers and they have a
lot of trouble with that getting the
planner in the ground so everybody
around me has taken the no-till Coulter
off and the fertilizer opener they've
gone to a smooth straight slicer disk
for the fertilizer opener so that they
don't have trouble with those open
holding the planner up out of the ground
great um why don't we move then last to
a Massachusetts and if you have any
questions from growers at your site you
have any questions on these folks
equipment situation let me and off the
mic here I think it was George we said
he only goes 13 inches deep is that
really adequate to get the plow pan on
your fields because here our fields have
been farmed about 350 years and packed
continually and I have to go down 17 or
18 inches get below it okay what I was
talking about was that to Row one that I
built from my strawberries there's no
compaction layers in that field because
I've zone told for years so I go down 12
or 13 inches when i plant strawberries
the big machine that's the regular
unverferth for planting soybeans or
sweet corner pumpkins I go about 17 or
18 inches if in the clay in the fields
where I have done it a number of years
and I don't have any compaction anymore
again I still only go 10 or 12 inches
there's no reason to go any deeper if
you don't have a density layer and it
pulls a heck of a lot easier 10 inches
deep tanned it does 18 so once you've
done it a few years you can quit going
so deep if you don't mess it up and go
back in there with a plow or disc or
something and put a layer back in right
or tie rod or something so you detect
where your compaction layer is so you
can rip just a little deeper alright
which is I check every field um is there
any other questions here I'm sorry any
other questions here looks like that's
it okay great Lynn I'm sorry I cut you
off you had a comment no I just started
saying I check every field I go around
once or twice I jump off and take the
pen a cometer and I'll check in the rip
and make sure i'm i'm breaking through
the hard fan that's how i determine how
deep i have to go in each field so most
of the time I just run it all the way
down but you can tell I just got to
listen to the tractor you can some
fields you can you could tell us pulling
hard he's
I'll just jump off and check in if I
don't have to run it as deep i will tend
to pick it up a little bit and do it
that way great um alright I think what
we want to do is um you got one more
question it's actually I have two
questions one question would be assuming
it's dry enough in the spring there any
good reason not to do the no tillage
preparation in the spring because
conventionally on Long Island we have
sandy loyal loam soils if we do feel
preparation the season before in the
fall we have wind and a water erosion I
I do all of my in the spring I cover
crop with rye and all just about all of
my ground and again like I said three
weeks to four weeks before i'm going to
rip i'll go through and sprayed with
Roundup and then go back through and do
my my tillage and that that seems it's
been a pretty good combination for me so
I don't have a problem with spring as
long as you can do the ripping two or
three weeks ahead of when you're going
to plant to let that row get healed up
and if you put the call to Packer on the
back you'll do a little better job the
problem is that slot will stay open and
you'll have loose soil for a while for a
short period after you do it until you
get a heavy rain or told it just
naturally settles in so I don't like it
in the spring if you've got to do it
with right away and then try to plant
right afterwards we had a trial in Wayne
County with Mike standard some years ago
on beings in the guy ripped today and he
planted the beans tomorrow and they were
terrible because he's planned beans in a
one inch wide slot that's sup nothin but
a big air pocket you have to either do
it into fall or do it far enough ahead
and spring so it heals up do we have do
we have Thomas off I don't see pneumonia
okay alright so we wanted to move to
Long Island because we had a growers
that we're using some slightly different
some different equipment there um and so
do we have Jen yeah we're here I knew
okay um so I did make I did put all of
the pictures for our gems to set up on a
powerpoint and I think Betsy sent that
out this morning I will put it up on our
screen as well so you can all see it so
go ahead Jen I'm just waiting for the
picture so I know what I'm talking about
hi this is thomas i am connected oh okay
Thomas will be right with you that is a
no-till grain drill that we part the
sunflower seven foot wide seven and a
half foot wide so that we can know till
cover crops into the fields that we are
resting for a year we grow pumpkins
specifically one year at rest one years
in pumpkins and one of our biggest
problems is fight a thorough and keeping
it away because we don't have enough
ground to rotate in so we're trying to
build up the soil to protect itself
against the fight otra so the no-till
drill is given us some options to try
other cover crops this past year we
tried oats and alfalfa that's it going
down the field so you can see that it
does a nice job in in the field without
tillage we also used it to plant sorghum
Sudan grass and third we planted our rye
in the fall which is about three bushels
to the acre and then we use the Rye in
the spring time as the mulch for the
pumpkins that is our zone builder that
was earlier in the season when we were
just testing it out and we had what
they're called the shark tooth reduced
residue managers and there in the front
of the Coulter
and then we also had Sharptooth behind
the culture and we found we had about
four bushels of ride to the acre this
past year so there was a lot of residue
on the field and we found that the even
the two sets of sharp teeth residue
managers were not clearing enough to
make a nice zone so what we did was we
got more aggressive residue managers
behind the culture and there should be
another picture that might be the one I
can't really see it well and that's it
yeah that's right that was earlier in
the season there that's the two shark
teeth and right there that's hardly any
residue but the pictures previous that's
where we had a ton of residue so we
found that putting the more aggressive
residue managers behind the Coulter
really helped push more of the Rye away
this was our first year using this zone
builder originally we've used a
waterwheel transplant to transplant our
pumpkins directly into the Rye and we
were noticing that they weren't there
wasn't as good of a stand they weren't
growing as well and we knew that they
needed more and this zone built up a
nice eight-inch zone where with fluffy
soil and they grew very well we just
need some more time to perfect it those
are some of the strips that you can see
that we prepared and it made a nice
little zone there and you can see the
amount of residue in between and there's
a lot of residue there even with all of
that residue though we had some trouble
with weeds so that's one of the
questions that we have is weed
management and also with that is also
the and there's the pumpkins and we put
t-tape down so that we can water and
also fertig ate with and another one of
our questions is fertilizer inside this
zone and is it being is there are the
weeds taking away from the fertilizer
and how we can compete with the weeds so
there's two issues in here it's the
taking care of the weeds and also
knowing if we need to do something
different with our fertilizer
at this point in time we have purchased
a John Deere planner up equi planner
corn planter that we would like to try
seating the pumpkins in the ground
rather than transplant planning because
it would take a lot less time and labor
I don't know if there's any other
questions how did you manage the rye
well you got a lot of you said you got a
lot of rye there how did you when did
you cut at what stage you cut it and how
did you get that that we manageable
we've tried several different we've
tried cutting it tall we've tried
cutting it short we have a flail chopper
that we've used we've had difficulty
with that when it's got to Totten too
tall so we use a rotary rotary mower
will cut it down and we'll go through
and fluff it up again what we're really
interested in is ruling we had just a
roller that we used to roller lon and we
tried rolling some of the the rye and
that seemed to work but we found that
you can't go in the same direction that
you are with the zone builder otherwise
that ride just wraps right up so we're
considering trying this you're going
cross ways and so we didn't know if
anybody had any experience with rollers
because there are rollers available that
we've seen on the front of tractors
right in front of their planner and they
go through and roll I'd plant right at
the same time so we're interested in
that as well we'd roll hi ride with a
color packer and planted right in it
pumpkins came up but we had problems
with fertility hmm pizza was real hmm oh
sorry about that gum Jen I wanted to see
if there was any questions any of the
questions from Massachusetts from any of
the growers there with the system um we
have one here hold on this is well he's
like house key we try and planning this
big awry as possible but we don't cult a
packet or roll it or anything we just
spray it with Roundup it's usually in
the head stage when we do it and
sometimes it works and sometimes it
doesn't it has to be really really dry
when we're working it though so you
don't tangle up when it's wet it's like
wire I don't know what's the advantage
not going to ride down that's what I
don't understand
yeah I can answer it but give me a half
a day to think about it my understanding
is if you let it drop and I've heard
that from Steve drop that it falls in
various directions and so it's harder to
play it into so we've what we've done is
we roll and then we hit it with Roundup
and that's just to keep the dress down I
don't think he could run a zone builder
through Lodge dry so if you're looking
to build a zone that might be a problem
the person from yeter that we talked
with used the analogy if you couldn't
comb your hair if one end wasn't
fastened and so rolling it down gives a
little more of an opportunity to work I
wonder if you couldn't kill the ROI what
it's standing and go through the zone
builder when it's standing without
knocking it down then you don't get that
once you knock it down even if you go
straight let's go get that it's not
perfectly straight look at that mixing
you know sometimes record if it's but if
standing you're not gonna get that
mixing to me its upright you might be
able to go through the for the Machine
and make it and make your zone what
about after with a plane tour though the
trade if a corner after the senior or
the transplant cedar cedar go right
through it cuz you're not know why don't
we do we have any other questions from
Massachusetts especially if you're not
going to not ride down just not affect
the light light getting to the crop of
pumpkins it knocks down when you plant
it guys would you run the wheels of the
tractor will run it over and it'll knock
most of it down you're better out what
we found George does it and I do it to
go leave it standing and go through that
way let the wheels of the track your
knock it down both between your deep
tillage and you're planning that it
opens it up at knacks probably
eighty-five ninety percent of it down
then the rest falls within a couple of
weeks
it'll fall down it looks good after
you've finished quite the key is you got
to get the roundup on the gray far
enough ahead so it's dead when you go to
planet and i agree with len i think i
can get through it with his own builder
and the planner much better if I haven't
rolled the one year that I did try
rolling it that it got too big you have
to go the same way with the role or you
can't go backwards or it all balls up
and I can't roll my field precisely
enough to know exactly where my planner
is going to go so I had big trouble out
here if you just kill it when it's about
24 inches tall or 30 inches I and let it
fall down and you've done it three weeks
before you're going to plant pumpkins
your planner won't have and the deep
teller won't have any trouble going
through there even if you go the same
direction it still tends to wind up on
the and the wheels of the planner yeah I
found it's far better to just leave it
standing when you go through it and it
doesn't seem to ball up at all once in a
while you get some but for the most part
it won't plug your wheels up and you
don't have to get back and chop that
stuff out of there great thanks Lynn um
because we are behind schedule i'm going
to ask folks to hold their questions for
Jen and we'll come back to